LONG, SO KEEP IT SIMPLE,
STRAIGHT AND H
OUT ON THE LEFT WING.
THE JACKETS MARCHED OUT STRAIGHT
ACROSS THE LINE.
>> HE'S OPEN IN THE MIDDLE THERE
AND HE'S ALONE AGAINST
JACKETS ON THE KILL HAVE S S THN
THE NHL THE CENA NICE PLAY TURNY
FAILED TO CLEAR.
THE JACKETS JUMP IT
AND BROKEN UP BY FABBRO WHO GOT
US TO CONFR THERE IT
IS IN FRONT.
HERE HE WINS THE DRAW.
TRENIN.
ANDREW
IT IS
THE NET.
THROWS A BEHIND THEIX AND
ONE.
RIGHT BEHIND A FIVE AND ONE ARE
ACROSS THE
LINE, MOVES IN.
PASSES, GATHER IT
AND  AND GET IT UP THERE AND
NICE SAVE BYHAT YOU LIKE
AND YOU WANT TO CHANGE YOUR
MIND, ANDITTLE STARE
DOWN THERE.
HE IS A CONFIDENCE GUY.
>> THEN.
TEXIERTEND THE SHOOTOUTELVIS.
KEEP GOING, JEFF.
TALVANEN WILLT
SHOOTER.
THEY JACKETS LEAD AND NEED